hi this is Brianna from free code camp
and today we're going to talk a little
bit about binary code now binary code is
a really really basic simple computer
language where there's just ones and
there zeros there's by two things ones
and zeroes ones meaning on zeros meaning
off so think of like a light switch
which in some cases and super old
computers there was an actual switch
which was eager on or off one thing on
zero being off so bunch ones and zeros
they can mean pretty much anything but
really they're mostly meant to be
numbers and letters we're going to go in
a little bit on how you actually decode
by near your translate a number two
binary code but really as you guessed
you can usually just google binary
translator and have that figured out the
most important part of this do you
understand the concept that even basic
things like zeros and ones can translate
into something really really complex and
it is the basis for all the computer
languages and programs that exist today